on and on and on with the mask mania  this marjorie taylor green  she compares it to the holocaust uh  which again  jesus [ __ ] christ do we really have  to let marjory taylor  green know what the holocaust actually  was i think that's the problem here  the problem is is marjorie taylor green  uh  is a neo-nazi and she denies that the  holocaust even happens  and the reason why she denies it because  she doesn't even know what happened  and because she doesn't know what  happened she she compares it to anything  she [ __ ] wants  and to compare the extermination of a  group of people  in in germany and europe in the 1930s  and 1940s  to putting a piece of cloth over your  face for uh several months  to make sure that you don't spread a  deadly pathogen to your family or  community  to keep them safe and healthy  is [ __ ] boneheaded but it's not  surprising coming out of her because  she's stunningly  a stupid piece of [ __ ]